In an age of increasingly ubiquitous
government, surveillance,
security breaches,
and high profile cancellations
in which internet giants have
ultimate control over users'
online profiles and data.
Microsoft is hwlping to build a technology
that would give individuals
ownership rights
over their own virtual identities.
The mission of the ION project
is to build decentralized
identifiers or DIDs
that can serve as the anchor point
for all our activities
across the internet.
To achieve this level of
decentralization and immutability,
ION is built on top of the shared database
that's used for recording
Bitcoin transactions,
which is known as the blockchain.
Though Microsoft is contributing most of the work,
the company would have no control over
who participates in the system.
If the goal of Bitcoin
is to eliminate the power of
central institutions over money
ION is trying to do the same thing
with online identity.
Daniel Buchner,
a self-described libertarian
is the project lead for ION.
Reason sat down with him
at the Bitcoin 2021 conference in Miami
to talk about how this technology
could usher in a new era
of hyper individualized
online identity and privacy.
Explain what a DID is.
Yeah, absolutely.
So if you're familiar,
you're all, everyone's familiar
with identity systems today.
I mean you use them
pretty much all day long
in your digital life.
Some of the good examples
of a digital ID today,
a centralized one.
are app usernames,
where you log in with
username and password,
social auth, that's usually
backed by an email address.
And those forms of IDs are
essentially leased to you
by companies, right?
So when you see all those
login buttons all over the web,
that's sort of a symptom of the disease.
The idea that you need to,
to be calling into these other authorities
is to essentially prove who
you are in the digital world,
much like Bitcoin,
and having a Bitcoin address
backed by strong cryptography
allows you to own your own monetary value.
ION enables you to own your own IDs.
So you can imagine an ID.
It doesn't look like an email address,
but it's wholly yours.
You can potentially log into websites.
You can get credentials issued
to you that you control.
And you're the only one
who can prove this ID
and no company owns it.
So there's no case
where someone shuts down
their email service,
and then you lose access to that ID
or lose the ability to
log in to certain services
you've associated with.
What of, what is the issues for
like, currently now, how has,
how has ION operating and
you know who who's using it?
How much?
Yeah, so we recently
announced a public preview
of Azure verifiable credential service.
And the first use case of
Microsoft really is credentials.
And what credentials are,
is anything issued to you by anyone?
Right?
So we think a lot about like diplomas
and workplace credentials, you know,
proof that you're an employee.
These things typically have been nascent.
They don't exist in a way that you can go
and prove it to someone else.
When you get your diploma,
it's sort of hangs on the
wall more of like an ornament
than anything that you
could really go and prove.
And that's bared out by looking
at LinkedIn and, you know,
you see all these people's
profiles, you really don't know.
Did they go to that school?
Like, is any of this information true?
What verifiable credentials
and DIDs together do
it allows you to, you know, for example,
go to university and get
a digital credential,
signed to an ID
that you can then turn around
and prove in a standard way
to everyone in the digital world.
And that's a, that's a huge leap, and.
So, is that, that helps cut
down transaction costs, right?
Because it's kind of like
an instant credit check.
You are who you say you are.
And all of the things that
you say about yourself,
to the extent that people are
going to want certain things
to be verified, like address,
education, skill set, and stuff.
So it just kind of eviscerates the need
for figuring anything out.
- Yeah, it definitely is
a business optimization
in the sense that you, you know,
what we've seen is the digitization of it,
a lot of different industries.
But identity for the most part,
human identity has remained
paper-based, analog, you
know, long processes.
And you see that all the time, right?
You're still filling out paper forms.
You're still showing people these things.
What we're doing is saying,
let's, let's bring
identity to where the rest
of the web has already
gotten over the last 20 years
and really advanced things.
What, what are the primary sticking points
to having this type of
thing more widely adopted?
So, really it's getting people accustomed
to services where they're
ultimately in control.
And, you know,
obviously as a libertarian
myself, you know,
I think that's a great thing.
I want people to be more in
control of their digital lives.
But it also requires more
responsibility and awareness
because most of the services today,
you always have this bailout
button, which is like,
you know, email recover from email
or something of that nature, right?
You don't have that, right?
At the end of the day,
an ION ID is wholly yours.
There is a, there is a loss condition.